One of the preferred and primary strategies
for Republicans to win elections for a long
time has been suppress the vote, make it more
difficult for people, especially people who
are less likely to vote for Republicans to
vote.
And this has been done a whole bunch of different
ways of reducing the number of polling places,
reducing early voting, purging people from
voter rolls.
There's a very long list of tactics we've
talked about over the years, and the 2020
strategy is going to be really suppress the
vote even more than usual.
We've already started to see it in some primaries
around the country and local elections.
And Kentucky is scheduled to have a primary
tomorrow and we may well be seeing the exact
same thing.
Now, normally there are thirty seven hundred
polling places in Kentucky.
Tomorrow there will be 200.
You didn't hear that wrong?
Thirty seven hundred.
There will be 200.
That's a 95 percent reduction in polling places.
Now, there's a double edged sword here and
the right wingers are trying to play both
sides of the coin, so to speak.
And the reason that's being given for this
reduction in polling places is because of
the corona virus pandemic.
A lot of poll workers don't want to work if
you can't staff polling places.
You have to close them.
Now, that is certainly plausible.
The problem is that in that case, you have
to ensure that people can vote by mail.
You have to increase capacity dramatically
at the polling places that will be open.
And there are widespread reports that people
who requested absentee ballots haven't received
them.
And it's the day before they have to be mailed
out.
They'd have to be postmarked by tomorrow,
Election Day.
So understand that on one hand, they are pretending
to respect the virus.
You can't put people in harm's way.
Great.
I mean, I'm totally with you as far as that
goes, but they're not doing what needs to
be done to make sure people can vote by mail
or vote early, which is exactly what Republicans,
including Kentucky Republican Senator Mitch
McConnell, who's up for reelection.
By the way, in November, and his his challenger
is going to be determined in this primary
tomorrow.
That's what McConnell wants.
That's what Donald Trump wants as well.
Now, some early voting has been enabled.
They at least claim that they're trying to
keep up with requests for absentee ballots.
But it's just not working.
And this is it's sort of a Hanlon's razor
situation, never a tribute to malice, that
which is adequately explained by stupidity
or I might say incompetence.
They claim that they did everything right.
Not enough poll workers.
So they said, hey, vote by mail, request absentee
ballots.
There's going to be some early voting, et
cetera.
A residents were sent postcards explaining
how mail in voting will work.
Early voting has been available in some places
since June 8th.
And the media and the governor, they've all
been telling everybody that this is this is
going on.
So there are people saying we did everything
we could.
We really did.
Given the circumstances.
But at the same time, you know, when you read
that half of Kentucky's black voters live
in one county and that county will have one
polling place, that's rarely a coincidence
when we see that type of thing around the
country.
So while I don't want to attribute to malice
that which can be adequately explained by
incompetence or stupidity or ignorance, when
you read that half of the black population
is in one county which will have one polling
place, it doesn't sound good.
It doesn't sound good.
And certainly to some degree they were unprepared.
I'm reading that instead of the normal three
to five days that it takes to receive an absentee
ballot application, some are taking upwards
of 20 days.
I've gotten emails from people in Kentucky
under that situation.
So what will happen tomorrow?
Well, we know what's going to happen, whether
it's malice or incompetence.
Tomorrow you are going to have overcrowding
post polling places that are open.
The ones that are open are going to be absolutely
busting at the seams up.
People will not have received their absentee
ballots in many cases, and they will have
to decide, do I go out and risk catching the
virus and maybe waiting hours and hours at
a completely overloaded polling place?
Or do I just not vote because I didn't receive
an absentee ballot in the mail?
And then you will have a situation that will
be similar to or even worse than the one we
saw in Georgia just a few weeks ago.
So there are some important decisions to be
made tomorrow in Kentucky.
There is, again, a Democratic primary race
to decide who will be facing off against Mitch
McConnell in November.
There is Amy Magrath Charles Booker and some
other candidates.
That's a big decision.
There are some interesting House primaries
as well for the eventual November House of
Representatives elections happening in Kentucky.
So this isn't nothing.
And again, it's all a preview of what's going
to happen in November.
The turnout tomorrow is not going to be as
big.
As the number of people that will vote in
November, because you will have everybody
coming out to vote for either Joe Biden or
Donald Trump, if you see chaos tomorrow, multiply
by 50 to imagine what it is that's going to
be happening in November.
Again, is it by design?
Is it incompetence?
Is it stupidity?
I don't know for sure.
It's often a competent combination of all
of the above.
Let me know what you think.